let me show you the perfect example of
how Insidious it is and and what do I
mean by Insidious slowly creeping yeah a
nefarious takeover yeah what do you
think when you when you know when the
left argues against this they say oh
critical race theories not based on Marx
and they lie not being taught in schools
we've just proven throughout the course
of this podcast that's those are Lies We
have the book right here critical theory
is the base for critical race there it's
obvious they call it critical race
Theory right Frankfurt School Marxism
Etc they say that you know they're
fighting racism and here's one of my
favorite lies this right here is from
Chris Murphy Chris Murphy is a U.S
senator from Connecticut with a million
followers Chris Murphy is either
dangerously stupid a cult member himself
or a grifter he says stop the woke mob
with a photograph of civil rights and
they're saying um you know here's one
you know we demand uh we demand an end
to what's it say racial Prejudice or
something or police brutality UAW says
unsegregated rules in public schools
stop the welcome mob I'm pretty sure if
you go to any intellectual dark web
Progressive or liberal or conservative
and ask them do you agree with that sign
and segregated rules in public schools
they will tell you yes of course we do
why would we want to stop this mob of
people we agree with and here's my
here's my response a clown Emoji
highlighting UAW says and segregated
segregated rules in public schools and a
photo I believe this was from Seattle it
could be wrong where they have a
diversity Equity inclusive inclusivity
session for people of color and next to
it for people who are white right they
are segregating this is what we are
complaining about share these things
with with your friends and family who
don't believe you who think but there
just trying to teach the history of
racism and Republicans are trying to ban
it no we're trying to make sure that
when they teach necessary of racism they
don't encourage more of it like Ibrahim
Kennedy does yeah and so we just filed a
thing that you're allowed to do in this
country that I don't even know about
called a civil rights complaint with the
office of civil rights it's with the
Department of Education and it was for
Wellesley Massachusetts Public Schools
so we all know about the tragedy in
Atlanta of the women and men also who
were shot and murdered right many of
them Asian so Wellesley Public Schools
this one school decides that they're
going to have a healing space so you
always love your healing space right and
you'd like to go you'd like to go
because this was a shocking story
White's not welcome I mean to be fair
you know you and I are both Asians so we
should we should just make sure
because you know what it was not my idea
oh there you go yeah so I I have in the
car you know another incarnation of this
that I didn't get to bring up
it's for it's for you in particular
where they now have uh hoodies
white Womanhood is white supremacy
because they gotta go away to you yeah
well actually we screwed it's all my
fault we do have this other story this
is funny parents at exclusive 57 000 a
year all girls private Manhattan school
right that counts Gwyneth Paltrow and
Katie and Kerry Washington among alumni
reject apology after video mocking white
women was shown to students
they're going to keep doing this stuff
yeah they are until people say no more
you know that this is unacceptable this
is values that we don't believe and they
can't the the thing that the thing that
we've learned is that you cannot be
shamed because the their tactic of
silencing people is to shame you and
people have to be Unapologetic in who
they are and what they believe and not
allow shame to silence them that's why I
like what you're doing it lets people
around the world really organize to show
like what's crazy in their you know
sector because if they come out one at a
time they get the vhmits they get the
Target and then they get shamed right
but if everyone's coming up together
yeah can't We're In It Together there's
no then you actually don't feel shame
when there's other people that are also
you know feeling your Vibe yeah yeah you
know one of the biggest problems I think
is is that you look at the groups that
are willing to stand up
it's just identitarians you know you've
got the alt-right who are going out and
marching and getting attacked or
whatever or like you know white
nationalists and whatever will come out
and they'll fight people and not so much
relative to the left the left will go
out with their you know surely in
protest many of them wear masks don't
don't want anyone filming but in their
workplace they'll wear masks that say
like black lives matter they will freeze
take them off they'll uh wear shirts
they'll get in trouble say we don't care
they stand up they yell they're secretly
going into schools they are actively
infiltrating government institutions
right and so what do you end up with
regular classically liberal-minded
Americans people believe in the founding
fathers aren't doing all that much
oh yeah we are we're fighting I am one
of those people you know I am always
voted Democrat I am a liberal I'm
classic liberal a feminist you know all
of these quote identities and
um I'm I'm fighting it in the same
reason why we fought in our Muslim
Community and keep fighting for reform
of those bad ideas because these are
ultimately bad ideas it's starting to
come up I think it's cause for Hope and
optimism especially you know with the
school season coming up we'll see how
things play because it really did
explode over the past year but what I
mean to say is you'll see antifa go out
and beat people yeah you'll see in some
circumstances you know there was one
recent thing I guess happened in
Philadelphia where some group came out I
don't know a whole lot about it but you
don't see moms marching against critical
race theory in the streets maybe yet so
maybe maybe that change needs to come
this year and then maybe we'll see it in
the next spring or fall yeah stay tuned
stay tuned it needs to happen yeah you
know more people need to go be at work
and say no to these these racist
programs yeah when you get you have to
you know choose and you know their new
buzzword affinity group is their new
buzzword right for segregation you have
to say no to it and you have to say that
I don't believe in segregation and you
know this uh taking men out of Lockheed
right for their white supremacy
retraining camp like they have to say no
to this yeah did you see the Sacramento
Public School System document where they
said they were one they wanted white
children to form white Affinity groups
to understand their history and shared
culture oh yeah I'm like that does not
sound like
I
guess anti-racism is just code word for
being racist because they support the
same things yeah I mean it really is
racism like anti-racism is racism
critical race theory is racism like
that's where we have to be straight up
about it anytime people judge people by
the color of their skin it's racism it's
like flammable and inflammable
right right exactly and um and you know
the real hope that I have is that that
people are running for school board
races now that that
you know techno that uh strategy that
they had to bring people into local
office parents are picking that up
they're doing it don't you love it that
the school systems the Educators they're
getting angry at parents because we're
filing Freedom of Information Act
requests they're like oh no how dare you
actually use your your citiz your right
as a citizen to demand contracts and
curriculum and so they're going after
parents for that but the parents are
doing it they're filing these these uh
requests I think it's time we start
calling them critical race application
practice sessions
I don't know maybe that's bad because
craps is a fun game yeah yeah yeah crap
only not crap critical voice Praxis I
like the Praxis word yeah because this
critical Grace theory is not racist
studying critical race Theory isn't
racist you're studying the tenets of
critical race Theory you're learning it
you're learning but integrating the
Praxis into your behavior is inherently
call it critical race in practice
yeah that's a nice one I like that yeah
then see when all the gang members are
like nah you see that video from the
there was a video from the salon where
this like Mexican dude or I guess was
fighting and people were saying that he
was like a gang member or something like
that and I'm like I don't know if that's
true whatever there might be people
being racist because the guy was like
Mexican they were like he's a gang
member because he's bald or something
like that right but I I do know that um
in Chicago
a lot of the Latin Kings very religious
and I have to imagine a lot of the older
you know members are not going to like
what they're done what they're doing to
these kids oh yeah I I mean there is so
much uh uh you know uh Kool-Aid that
they're forcing kids to drink and they I
mean what parent wants that because
especially if you have a pride in your
identity you don't actually want people
to start saying that you are the
oppressed right like you are trying to
actually teach your child that you are
empowered and you can do whatever you
want to do and so there's a mom named
Norma she came from Peru and she is just
so angry that they are making such
assumptions about hispanic kids you know
yeah she's like this is insulting and
and I don't I don't uh she says I don't
um hate Asian kids that might be going
into this school I actually learn from
them like what is it that their parents
are teaching them that about good values
there's this viral tweet I guess where
someone said that English is the
colonizer's language and to speak
Spanish or whatever people are like uh
Spain like what do you like there was a
conquistadors dude right so brutal yeah
and you know there's such myopia in this
telling of quote truth a few weeks ago I
went to one of the protests by the
social justice educators of DC yeah and
there they were chanting like a cult I
pledge to teach the truth and it's their
truth that's the problem some people are
saying critical race at practice oh nice
I like that crap sessions yeah right
right crap they're teaching crap to our
children language yes don't call it crap
it's critical no no it's critical race
at practice I love the I love the
creativity because basically we've got
to how do you how do you dismantle
propaganda right yeah yeah propaganda
yeah
propaganda right when I was at the skate
park I mean I see these little kids and
they're sitting you know they got all
this graffiti propaganda of black lives
matter and other woke nonsense and then
me and my friends started laughing about
like what loser is gonna come out here
and be like Walmart what up up like I'm
repping walmart.com and the kids there
hear us mocking the ideas that's what
you need you need to go there and
basically be like I'll tell you what
happens you go to a skate park and you
see a bunch of kids and the the alpha
kid you know the kid who's good is going
like yo black lives matter yo but then
when a pro shows up someone who's older
and really good and they do a Trey flip
crook down the ten rail that all the
kids are like oh and then he starts
making fun of the kids for their stupid
propaganda those kids will change their
tune in two seconds yeah but then that
that pro has to have the courage right
to be able to do that and they don't the
challenge is then they're afraid of
losing their sponsorships their
endorsements and all the rest all it
takes is for some
um charismatic individuals to be there
to to be to inspiring young people and
telling them to get away from that
propaganda you don't even gotta be doing
Trey flip I listen to your interview
with Candace Owens and she said and you
said also that you get so many phone
calls right and so many conversations
with so the quote a list that afraid to
come out of the closet yeah I've been
criticism but but they believe it
they counter this belief I was I was
invited to a couple like A-list or
Hollywood parties and I was like why
would you why would why like why would I
go to this they're like oh man it's like
it's low-key you know you got anything
to worry about and I'm like I don't have
anything to worry about it's you guys
you're scared to speak up you're right
there's like it was it was like TV show
A-list it wasn't like you know Robert
Downey Jr or anything like that it's
like a bunch of people who are in
prominent shows we're going to be at
this Hollywood party and I was just like
I I the idea that
you know with all due respect I'm gonna
come out and have a good time and laugh
and and and and you know break bread and
have a beer with you guys when you're
sitting here saying we completely agree
but we will never defend you publicly
I'm like I'm not cool with that yeah
yeah and it is tough and I uh you know
now I don't know about you all but like
I am just uh surround myself with folks
who are challenging this kind of
ideology because I don't want to be
dragged down by people who are just
hemming and Hauling and cowardly really
in society like I get it because I went
I've reported in Pakistan and in
Afghanistan you know and Saudi Arabia
where ex extreme identity politics kills
right and and I I really fear for
America like we are headed in that
direction and I don't want that like
when you were talking about the Target
closing at six o'clock I thought to
myself man that's what happens like in
war zones right that's what happens
that's what would happen in a country
like Pakistan fun because it's dangerous
after dark and that's where sectarianism
kills and and all the immigrants from
Lebanon Iraq you know Egypt like they
understand the dangers of this China yes
Eastern Europe right yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time